um my TV show came and went I'm gonna
post a link here in that first opening
box underneath my video um it was a
Cameron what they called it but it was a
program on Canada's global television
network on prime-time devoted to this
question of polyglot sir they choose the
term hyperpolyglots which I must say I
think is a ridiculous term let me just
say that polyglot is polyglot I like the
word linguist people who speak many
languages once we've got five you can
make it 10 you can make it 15 I don't
think it makes much difference I was a
bit disappointed no Keith Swain who has
a channel here YouTube it calls himself
the Canadian linguist and whom I got to
know and it's a great guy he and I flew
out from Vancouver Alexander who is
another very nice fellow who came from
Winnipeg although he's originally from
Quebec
to participate we flew all the way out
there we were in a conversation with a
total of five of us including axel from
Toronto and James who's also from
Toronto and we'd spoke for two hours and
a very interesting discussion about
language learning and so forth and so on
and I think we we managed to survive to
the tune of about a minute and a half
which I guess is inevitable but I
thought our discussion was it was quite
interesting and I certainly enjoyed the
getting to know all those people or
getting know them better in the case of
Keith what annoyed so I was annoyed that
we didn't have more of our discussion I
was also annoyed at the sort of
suggestion although they didn't really
come out conclusively and say so but the
implication that somehow someone who
speaks
ten or fifteen languages is strange and
this is an idea that I think again this
Michael I think air are you wrote the
book babble no more kind of just kind of
dances around the edges of this
position but doesn't come up and say so
but that there seems to be the
suggestion of there's something
different about the brains of people who
could speak many languages and I don't
believe this is the case except to the
extent that as you learn anything your
brain changes and if you are a violinist
your brain will change the more you play
the violin um they've done surveys to
show that that part of your brain for
example that can controls the movements
of your fingers will get larger at the
famous London taxi drivers who who's
part of the brain which controls you
know detailed things that relate to
names of streets and where they're
located that's gonna grow so yeah if use
if you go to the trouble of learning ten
or fifteen languages your brain is gonna
be a little bit different however
there's just too many people on me I'm
studying check now and and I'm listening
to my my wonderful series on check
history and so this Czech nationalists
of the early nineteenth century
frantisek Polanski is introduced and he
spoke fifteen or sixteen languages well
of course because he lived in the
Austral in the in Austria at that time
the Austrian Empire he spoke Czech
German Slovakian Hungarian and then and
Croatian and then there were so many
languages there that Latin was the
common language in the church so he
spoke Latin and I can't remember what
other languages he spoke but there are
any number of countries I've heard that
in Ethiopia it's not uncommon for people
to speak four or five languages if you
live in an area where there are a lot of
different languages spoken you're gonna
end up speaking a lot of different
languages don't tell me that all those
people are musical left-handed have
immune deficiencies or whatever other
strange things that they mentioned on
this on this TV program I firmly believe
that language learning is a matter of of
the determination of someone their will
their desire their their interest their
need their opportunity to speak first
one language then a second and a third
and then if papers decide to pursue
learning
language they learn more of them it's
not more complicated than that
the difficult language the most
difficult language is the first foreign
or non-native language that we learn
because and that was my experience
because we don't know that we can do it
we think it's it's just and especially
if you live in North America sort of or
if in China or even in Japan or in any
country where really you only need the
local language
now I lived in Montreal so theoretically
I need the French but in fact we didn't
because Montreal in the 50s was a 1
million english-speaking people who
didn't speak to the two million
french-speaking people that's no longer
the case now you need it so now there's
a high percentage of bilingual people in
Montreal amongst both the francophones
and the Anglophones and in many cases
they're trilingual because they might
speak Italian French and English
extremely well for example our
goaltender here at in Vancouver on the
Vancouver Canucks
I mean he's almost native like in
Italian French and English I don't think
he's necessarily a weirdo with some
immune deficiency I think there are many
people like him I know many people in
Montreal who's who today who have their
college you know the language of their
immigrant parents and English and French
and in some cases one more so it's two
minutes it's not as something strange in
your brain it's it's more a matter of
whether you apply yourself to the task
whether you have the opportunity whether
you choose to pursue it and as I say
once he get past the first one the
second one becomes easier and so on and
so forth plus you pick up some freebies
you know Richard Simchat was featured
which is great because I think Richard
is a super guy he was featured in this
TV series and he speaks a lot of
languages and he speaks languages from
different language groups I'll be a
European up until his recent venture
into Turkish but once you've got you
know he speaks Macedonian Bulgarian
Serbian I don't know check I mean those
are very similar languages French
Spanish Portuguese so once you venture
out there if you speak Dutch you can
learn Afrikaans the German is not far
behind so if your goal
is to rack up a lot of languages which
I'm not suggesting that's Richards goal
but I'm saying that this whole numbers
thing is a little bit misleading
not only can you rack up numbers by
studying related languages but as I say
the more you learn the more comfortable
you get so you'd be surprised if you
decided to to to work towards speaking
20 languages yeah if you put in the time
you can do it you know and and I think
Richard is a I've spoken to Richard he's
a perfectly normal guy Lukas a normal
guy the guys that we spoke to down there
we're all normal guys I'm a bit weird
but by and large it's normal people who
have a strong interest in speaking
languages other people are interested in
other things
so I just want to die I got quite
annoyed or I do get annoyed at this
suggestion that somehow it's something
weird are certain people more talented
than others yes but I think that that
Richard and Luke are both extremely
talented and especially because I've
heard Luca speak so many different
languages his his pronunciation is
absolutely excellent and my own view and
he'll probably disagree I think he's
it's because he's good at it he and and
how why is he good at it
I think it's an attitude thing I think
he listens well although to be fair
again his English sounds to me
non-native like which is fair enough he
speaks it extremely fluently
however I've heard native speakers tell
me that his German sounds native his
Swedish is almost native his Russian I
thought his Chinese was pretty
spectacular
not to mention okay give him the French
Spanish that's romance whatever he's
lived there fine but it's these others
that he does so well so I think he's
talented
and I think the ability depend I think
Richard is talented but I think the a
bit and perhaps I have a greater
facility to pick up or to get closer to
native pronunciation than some other
people but as I've always said I don't
think that matters so much I know people
like you know that I've worked with who
who who really speak English well but
who have a very strong accent it
matter so I think the accent is where
there could be differences in talent but
I think the rest of it is more a matter
of how much effort you're willing to put
in your attitude your confidence your
determination your interest your your
love for the language and all those
other good things so thank you for
listening bye for now